[Applause]
this is odder than i thought it would be
do you ever get over the fact that
my expression through the whole movie is
tom cruise
he really is you know it's just straight
up all those movies
and he looks just the same
at the top of your game it's phenomenal
and this is apropos nothing but i was a
kid and i went to america and the first
movie i saw in america was like an
audience test screening of risky
business come on i know really i'd fill
in the car and i could have wrecked your
career
but that was kind of that was the
beginning really
isn't it
do you remember kind of the moment when
fame hit and you thought oh actually i
can't arrange to meet a friend outside a
coffee shop anymore i can't you know
your life changed do you remember your
life changing yeah i remember right
after
yeah it did right after risky business
it changed a lot and then top gun
it was
very good
he said top gun
i feel like we shouldn't ask any
questions we'll just sit here and look
at him for a while
oh
now tom please you aren't legendary for
the amount of time you spend with your
fans and the signings and all that time
when you meet your fans you've got this
huge back catalogue of movies so do
people want you to like do lines for
movies do they do catchphrases is there
any particular categories they always
want to hear well there's different ones
from different films you know that
sometimes they'll ask or they'll they
actually kind of shouted at me sometimes
you know and it's the one that's top of
the list
there's not like one no
basically i was like do something oh
okay oh yeah all right okay i'm sorry
yeah
okay
[Applause]
okay amuse us with some patrons
yeah you complete me you had me at hello
[Applause]
[Music]
oh help me help you
i want the truth
oh yes oh do i feel the need for speed
sometimes you just got to say what the
yeah obviously business yeah
oh
risky business i don't know
10.
i'm coming here i i sound like your
mother because
you
you do the stunts and i worry for you i
work i just think stop now
luck running out
you know there's only so many times you
can do these crazy things like the last
mission impossible you learned how to
hold your breath underwater tell the
people how long this is incredible how
long could you hold your breath for
underwater six and a half minutes
good right
those takes underwater because it took
from the time you get rid of the
regulator get rid of the bubbles
get on the side and we wanted to do it
in one shot so there were very very long
shots so these takes took you know
they'd i'd have to hold it consistently
you know safely up to four minutes
almost for every take almost to the
point of why bother
i know but we were committed everyone
was there the camera was set up
i'm just like what am i gonna say it was
too late to say no how is that possible
is it circular breathing do they do that
no it's just you have these free divers
that came in and trained me how to do it
and it's
it's it's not pleasant
it's really kids you
no actually you you get to the moment
where you train your your uh
your system to i'm now under i'm
controlling the breath so i've got a low
heart rate anyway and i would very low
heart rate which means my body's not
using as much oxygen but also we did
stuff to bring the heart rate down lower
and certain breathing exercises
and i trained for a long time to the
point when i finished the sequence
there'd be times i'd be sitting there
talking in meetings and i wouldn't
breathe i realized i am not breathing
and i had to turn my autonomic system
back on to breathing in that's bad
that's bad
that was a little i i did that so i'm
done with that but actually jude though
no no no stop it
first the runnings
in the young pope you do hold your
breath for about 40 seconds
it was quite a long yeah it was no six
and a half minutes but it was a long
time yeah it's no six half minutes
thank you
did you train for it so you know you
still want agony i mean it's painful i
didn't actually because it's not it what
it really isn't that long uh
basically
it was it was in the script that uh he's
uh he's he's he's had this trauma i
don't want to give anything away uh he
he give him a little bit he has a prayer
and he decides he wants to get away from
everyone so he's in the bottom of his
palatial swimming pool so that the shot
starts on the back of me and we had to
time the length of the prayer
over a minute let's say that yeah and it
comes around and we had the time you
said it comes around and like you're
saying the thing that takes the longest
is once you're down there you're waiting
for the bubbles to clear yes and they're
ready and then you hear
well because they've got microphones in
so you're awkward
then you start to feel you do a little
pain
because i would i was just trying to
count it or or recite the prayer but
then i worried that the prayer would
start changing speed so i started
counting and then i knew every time i
got to like 70 i was always starting to
think okay i hope they're there soon
because then i had to
trust that they were in front of me for
when i opened my eyes do this and then i
go up so wow but it was no six and a
half minutes
still you know that pain i mean i had to
train
stuff to do the first time i did it was
like yeah learning that kind of stuff is
honestly i think yep
no six and a half minutes no uh but it
is it's a perk you know you learn to do
these weird things and wonderful things
so not a useful thing to know how to do
i mean
learn french
say you're out with you know when you
get thrown out of the boat and you're
down there now you know how to hold your
breath i could stay alive for an extra
six minutes
you beat them all
yeah he was the last one to die
you're the last one to go yeah
you get to wave them all goodbye
they all hate you as they die yeah
that's impossible obviously you're pays
your money you want the the big big
stunts now last time you were on the
show you were kind of hinting at this
big set piece in this movie that you
spent years preparing yes so i think you
can tell us a bit more about it now
right now i could tell you a bit more
okay i spent uh
really two years mc and i were talking
about a sequence and it's an aerial
sequence with helicopter and i've wanted
i've studied you know many different
films and
so when i went and i got my helicopter
license and we're flying uh airbags
i was surprised you didn't have a
helicopter license
it's also not you
when they were telling me you got it and
he got his head away
really i'm sure i've seen him flying
helicopters before were you flying
without a license previously yes not to
get into trouble or anything but yeah
so who were you okay sort of wonder you
got it quickly i know i know it's very
fast okay so you get the license yeah
and then we uh you know we just started
really working on the sequence to see
what can we do practical i mean i think
in terms of action this is probably the
largest practical action film ever shot
like when you look at the films there's
no cgi so we're going through paris the
motorcycle it's just full-on cars you
know we're all doing our own stunts
and the helicopter sequence is just
incredibly
uh exhilarating and very dangerous so
there's really only one country that
would allow us to do it where we had to
build special camera rigs
for the helicopter and so i got my
license and we just i trained up on
aerobatics and it's different i fly
aerobatics and airplanes but helicopters
are very different so we're flying very
low very close to rock faces in a chase
and i'm chasing you know henry into
sequence and we've got some pictures of
it here so now this is so there you
that's you fly this is the end of the
sequence or the beginning i think we've
got these pictures the wrong way around
i think no there it's
i can't tell you that right now okay
it's part of the scene all right well
well i just think this might be out of
the room because there's henry hanging
out of the house there's henry back
there flying he's hanging out he's not
even flying a helicopter
what he had to do
because we're doing aerobatics he's
at least i know my own fate you know he
was there at times he was literally on
the on his tail like a foot off the tail
rotor at times he had no idea there were
times where i genuinely thought it was
like okay this is how it goes
dedicated at least i get killed by tom
cruise
henry's lucky because he can actually
fly anyways yes of course
[Applause]
so here you are now i'm guessing so that
must be after this next bit because this
next picture you're on the outside so
someone must be flying that helicopter
it can't be
please tell me you didn't get out of the
helicopter
while it was going
so that's that's you
i mean and it is it's it's that is you
hanging over the helicopter but this
next picture
is one it's just a beautiful picture but
it's crazy so
that's you yes i mean that okay i know
right i can tell i can tell by this
you're quite high
we were on the ground that day we're in
the ball hanging on
the rest of the
and because
you know tom does all this stuff does
that mean that you guys have to say yes
to
want everybody they can't wait you can't
get these guys out of the stunt room do
you know what henry's like in the
helicopter he's loving it you were
freezing in that helicopter oh we had a
client yeah it's new zealand winter and
the doors are open you posted a picture
you posted a picture on your instagram
of you doing a stunt which looks very
painful it should be i think it's you
being lowered down a cliff by your
nipples
i love the stiff neck and the thumb
yeah i'm fine
it's one of those moments where you're
you're being lowered off this eighteen
hundred foot cliffs
yeah one of those moments
i know i'm perfectly safe because the
stunt crew is absolutely fantastic
eastwood team is they're just they're
really good you trust the harness and
they've all triple checked everything
but it's still 1800 foot backwards
it's so high and the boats at the bottom
in the fjord are about this big
that it looks like a painting and so you
lose all sense of like fear and
adrenaline for the height you start
thinking if i were to fall could i kind
of like squirrel suit with my
make it all the way to the water maybe
just like skim
you've been in superman too much
uh you know with child now so that makes
stunts harder but even when you did the
last movie you seem quite unsuited i
mean don't you did suffer from vertigo
going into these oh yeah so i mean that
does seem a bizarre thing to say yes to
being in one of these films
well i didn't really know what i was
saying yes to
okay
i don't really know how these films were
made so you know when i was on the camel
in the desert
very quickly and then the first day of
shooting tom what did we do
we jumped off a building yeah
the first day of shooting i think we've
got a picture of you so that that
that's me swearing and shouting the
naughtiest words ever
in my ear in your ear
i'm so sorry swear switzerland did i say
that i'm so sorry
i'm just so
the worst words ever
and then we jump off and he just looks
at me and the tom cruise comes away and
goes
welcome to missionary
[Applause]
[Music]
you said it to all of us
i remember my special day too
now normally and gentlemen on a show
like this we would uh show a clip of mr
possible but you haven't finished the
film yet sorry so uh
it's not gonna happen so we thought we'd
make it a snatch of one of our own now
uh one of the most iconic stunts that
you do tom is that running away from
something exploding you're very good at
it thank you very much we've got some
stills there's uh running away from a
van
oh that's in the channel tunnel there
this is the exploding fish tank oh yeah
there you go
joe i've just looked that's a very good
movie i like that's down that's x score
that is very good
so i think presumably timing is key
because these are real they're real
explosions they're real explosions so
yes that one was particularly very crazy
was this the one where no one properly
told you the timing yeah the guy was
over there and he said okay we're gonna
go on three and he started going three
two one i said whoa whoa stop stop
and then we'll stop waiting you know we
have an explosion's going to go in my
head and he said i said
you just said on three
he said well i meant three
what does that mean
so now we're gonna go i said just
everyone's please it was like two in the
morning and they're setting it up and
there's broken there's glass and just
tons of water and
he said well i'm gonna three two one and
i said then i do i go then or do i go do
i go on one like when do i go
do i go on one are you going to push the
button is it going to explode on one
it was you know it kind of looked at me
like
i don't know
i'm not sure
[Laughter]
what we've done is uh we've got a green
screen here so we could raise up the
green screen at
a great speed
while we're waiting for that
we're gonna get some members of the
audience should to do this but in terms
of this tom so what we're gonna do is
they're gonna start back there they're
gonna run
they're gonna run okay
they're gonna run to here
and then that's the type of experience
and then they're gonna want to get a
height
and presumably facial expression so what
in terms of jumping what's the best way
to get height
are they going to land in the mats yeah
that's the idea first of all watch your
ankle on the mat because
he knows this he knows it okay let's get
some people let's get people to do this
uh we'll might we'll get to you hang on
uh who now uh who wants to do it you
want to you want to do it okay you can
come do it come do it what's your name
jamie jamie lovely okay jamie
so tom tips for jamie before so what
sort of a facial expression should you
go for um
whatever it feels natural just
most important thing is don't get blown
up don't get bored
yeah you're trying not to do it
i'm escaping you're escaping you're
escaping but you're brave
yeah you're great he's great yes you
know you've got to look terrified you're
frightened but you're still brave yes
frighten the brain i'm not going to go
too high
what i'll do for you i like that
what's the countdown is it three two one
three two one go okay so you're going on
one on three one
let's go you do it suddenly three two
one okay here we go here we go jamie
okay so it's three
two
one go
oh
that was good
[Applause]
okay
let's see it let's see it oh there's
jamie he's running he's running
[Applause]
do
you'd like to do it okay here you go
here you go you are in that dress
okay fine what's your name
maddie all right buddy up here there you
go okay here comes maddie now so you saw
jamie yeah you saw jamie so it's very
important that you just piss all over
that
okay buddy so women just do it the same
right rebecca yes we do we do absolutely
and think you go think
up okay i want you to think up elevation
we're looking for elevation next your
face jamie was like a stone
one thing one thing jamie did when jamie
did it which you saw in the playback was
it looked like jamie did a really big
fart
don't do that
okay here goes maddie here goes okay so
here we go three have fun two
one go
[Applause]
oh
okay here's maddie
[Applause]
should we do one more one more one more
let's get someone uh
uh you'd like to do it oh you'd be so
good at it go wrong have a go have a go
dude come on
right now you're fish
at the moment you're okay okay
okay you've seen the others you've seen
the others i think the important thing
is particularly because you look so
beautiful big face at the end okay so
we're looking for high chair evelyn
heights take my
and then forward okay
okay yeah you're good okay okay okay
okay this is evelyn
[Applause]
there we go okay let's have a look
good job
let's watch evelyn
[Applause]
i'm nearly
finished hope so you've been filming
since when last year last year last
march or april i mean so it's been a
year yeah yeah so you must be nearly
finished it's cause i broke my ankle we
had to shut down but we're about six
weeks away the ankle this is that so are
you fully recovered are you well it's
still broken but i'm doing well no
you're kidding is it still broken yeah i
mean it's not fully healed but we're
shooting but that's nuts because we've
seen no you've seen a picture of you
you're running and doing all this stuff
again yeah now but we have a release
date so we got to keep going yeah
otherwise you'll end up going live
much better
you probably i'm sure you all saw the
the footage in in it was on the papers
and things on online of the accident yes
and i think we all kind of thought well
how did you break an ankle doing that
does it look like you should have broken
your jaw or something i know everyone
said that was the stunt i mean i'm going
to run across
and hit the side of the wall and then
pull myself over that wasn't the mistake
so you're always meant to not yes land
on the roof
okay so what you've done is you brought
us some footage i think this is so cool
to see this from the different angles
this is what i i can't watch
this i haven't watched it
most of it's fine there's one clip but i
will warn you it's not for the squeamish
growth you see i'm wearing two wires
they're basically just safety wires
because i go to full tilt and i'm
sprinting as hard as i can and i hit the
side of the wall and that's the stunt i
hit the side of the wall and then i'm
chasing after henry actually
and uh
all his fault i blame him i hit the side
of the wall and then i i climb up on the
wall and i'm supposed to run past kevin
okay so we've got uh this is the shot
from behind you so this is you see the
the speed and the momentum of the run
and it's in london there we go so it's
keeping the uh okay so here he goes look
at that whoa and
now it's good noise everybody
but you get my point that you think how
did you break a leg so let's look at it
from the side this is it from the side
no no no no this isn't a bad one this
isn't the bad one rebecca so this is
from the side here we go we shot it with
three cameras okay here he goes and boom
now now we've got our camera which
focuses on the foot now if you are
squeamish
don't watch this because it still hasn't
seen it
keep trying to show it to me and i'm
like yeah
i mean a bone doesn't pop out or
anything but it is an odd angle for
anyone's foot to be nobody's foot should
ever have to do this yeah here we go
here we go oh my gosh so he jumps that
speed that momentum here we go
and now watch that watch this
but here here is why here is why tom
cruise gets paid the big bucks okay
because this is it from the front angle
okay so you've just seen what's happened
to his foot now watch this i knew i
broke it instantly so you're down now
anyone else would go well that's over no
up he gets
a pig
and he's running
[Applause]
i didn't want to do it again i knew i
knew instantly it was broken and i
i just run past camera we got the shot
it's in the movie that profile shot both
those shots are in the movie
and henry everybody said when when you
got up and ran out of shot oh that's so
him
to complete the shot like with your foot
hanging off
[Laughter]
i just went i said sorry guys it's
broken you know take me to the hospital
it's broken that's a wrap everyone
everyone crew got on the phone and made
their vacation arrangements i made a
baby
[Music]
you